la chronique sport comme tous les lundis
Anthony et on va parler ce soir avec
notre invité de tirub aquatique oui on
va rester pas mal dans l'eau ce soir
avec nous oui cette saison aussi he
ouais tout à fait cette saison
exactement avec nous sur le plateau
Sylvain bentoubal vous êtes le
responsable de la section de tir
subaquatique de la palme pliroise le
club de plongé de plaisirou bonsoir à
vous bonsoir et vous allez nous
accompagner donc durant les les
prochaines minutes pendant cette pas jeu
sport mais on va débuter par quelques
résultats du tennis tout d'abord ouais
un petit résultat en tennis c'était la
reprise du du championnat de France ce
weekend pour plaisir euh les équipes
premières hommes et femmes sont toutes
les deux en première en première
division en Nationale 1 le club livinois
s'appuie essentiellement cette année sur
sur les jeunes comme comme Éric fondba
mais la marche du championnat de France
reste élevée les les joueurs plaisirrois
qui font office de petit poussé à côté
de mes de Toulouse de Grenoble se sont
inclinés samedi et dimanche des fêtes 5
5 des hommes face à et 60 chez les
femmes face au club de saint-ier
l'objectif reste le maintien pour
Charles giordiano le président du club
de plaisir justement je vous propose de
l'écouter au micro de Guillaume
CS et on va écouter on va
l'écouter c'est sûr que championat du
monde voilà si si on on a la chance de
le gagner on peut pas être plus haut
quoi je dirais puis bon surtout que ça
ça s'est passé à Marseille avec 6000
spectateurs voilà c'est il y avait une
ambiance particulière voilà pour cette
interview qui n'a rien à voir on parlait
plutôt pétanque dans cette interview
P est-ce qu'on a réussi à mettre la main
sur cette interview du président du club
de tennis de plaisir pour faire un petit
point sur cette reprise de saison oui
justement qui qui évoquait le le
l'objectif maintien pour cette saison
voilà on va éc cette année si on se
maintient et ben je seraai plus que ravi
je serai plus que ravi donc voilà
l'objectif alors ça va être dur parce
que nous avons des jeunes que nous
mettons le à qui nous mettons le pied à
l'érier les les le petit chat là le
petit fond bas qui viennent de d'accéder
à des classements intéressants et bien
voilà j'ai choisi cette formule làà et
voilà donc pour le tennis c'est mieux
avec la bonne interview c'est c'est
mieux avec la B intervie des terrains et
des balles jaunes